akira the dawn is a british musician dj
and producer
he's worked in genres as diverse as pop
hip hop indie dance and more recently
perhaps something that has come to be
known as lo-fi
for reasons that have been quite
surprising to me akira has been making
lo-fi tracks also known as meaning wave
a combination of metered spoken word and
music chosen for its emotional and
conceptual appropriateness from some of
my sayings and my talks
they have been reasonably well listened
to garnering maybe a million views over
the 10 or 15 or so that he has posted on
youtube
the two main albums 12 rules for life
and jbp wave genesis have elicited more
than a million streams each on spotify
and that doesn't include itunes and
other content providers of the same type
the third album oriented around my words
will be entitled jbp wave paradise
it will be released a week today
earlier this week akira also released a
long single 42 rules for life based on
the totality of the rules i had written
for quora several years ago i think i'll
feature that on today's podcast
akira has also produced similar works
featuring ellen watts jocko willink who
is currently number one in the meaning
wave charts terence mckenna david foster
wallace and elon musk among others
overall spotify downloads have topped 4
million
and he's experiencing an approximate
exposure at the moment of about a
million a month
so welcome akira it's nice to talk to
you we've met a little bit before not
not a lot as i became aware of what you
were doing this is the first time really
that we'll have a chance to talk in any
great detail yes we've emailed
so what are you up to
bluntly
i'm i'm you know i'm engaged in an
experiment in uh ridiculous
hyperproductivity
and uh zone inhabitation
uh
my idea being well basically you know
i'm working on this music
but aside from working on the music i'm
working on
remaining in the zone of making music so
the music uh flows and becomes better
and better and better and my whole
process becomes more efficient and
powerful
with each thing so it's this combined
thing of of making this this new form of
music or
this
nothing's new is it making this form of
music
and
doing it in a hyper productive and
powerful fashion okay so let's start
with hyper productive
so because you said you had twin
ambitions and so what's the hyper
productive element well i've released
is it five albums this year so far four
or five albums this year so far we're in
march
it's march
since the beginning of 2019 indeed oh
yeah okay well that that seems to
qualify as hyper productive especially
if this also happens to be a difficult
endeavor
it is it is but
here's the thing i i noticed uh i used
to be a music journalist
and there's this phenomenon
wherein band's first albums are amazing
and uh then their second albums are
often not amazing
and there are a bunch of reasons for
this but i i figured the main thing
is a band will be locked in a garage
playing together every day for years and
years and years
writing songs together and so on and so
forth and their first album will be the
sum of that they'll have essentially
been in a kind of flow and the first
album will be the fruits of that flow
and then the record company usually
sends them on tour for a couple of years
at which point they fall out of that
flow of writing songs all the time
and when they go back into the studio
they've sort of
fallen out of that zone
so i wondered to myself what would
happen if one got in the zone and then
refused to leave
if one just got in the state of just
constantly
creating uh with a very specific sort of
mission and purpose
and uh and found out foundational sort
of meaning behind it so one doesn't get
discouraged or whatever
and uh just kept doing that what would
happen and i've been doing that since
last february
and uh the results have been
beyond what i could have uh
hoped for
and okay the results being beyond what
you could have hoped for along what
dimensions what's
what's changed for you over the last
couple of years like
what's this
what was your career like before you did
this and what's changed as a consequence
for you
in your career and well let's also say
personally
a lot i mean uh previously
i mean i've been doing this uh you know
as sort of my job
uh since
full time
around 2000 2004 i got my first record
deal
with uh which was with interscope
records in america after a bizarre
sequence of events
um and yeah i've been making music
full-time ever since and dj
uh however previously if you kind of
look at my catalogue
you know there would be many many years
between releases
and uh the old model of the music
industry which i was i was sort of
trapped in um
which was completely my own fault
because i had yet to
to imagine
another way fully um
you know you spend years making an album
is the idea and then you spend years
promoting it for a long time promoting
it and it's all about getting press and
all these sorts of things
and um
i would get sort of discouraged
and sad if i would i'd spend a lot of
time making a thing
and then i would go to sort of put it
out and i wouldn't have all the
resources that i
felt that i wanted or needed to get it
to all the people that it should get to
um which is kind of the old model
whereas now what i'm what i'm doing part
of what's going on now is i'm just kind
of releasing a vast amount of stuff at a
very very high level and uh it sort of
compounds
right now you know the time is different
in the internet
yes i'm in the internet
a week is a very very long time so these
days i make sure some new music comes
out every week
and yes well the internet
radically accelerates the production
schedule of everything i mean we're
going to make this video and
hypothetically i could release it this
afternoon
crazy thing to do with uh
well with a with a
what's essentially a semi documentary
i mean
unheard of you know look at your camera
quality
amazing you know we're all walking
around with uh with devices in our
pockets that are better than the things
they made uh 2001 a space odyssey with
yeah yeah well it's a very and the
consequence of that speed acceleration
is very
um
psychologically dramatic as well because
it also becomes something that you have
to feed on a very regular basis
like the plant in little shop of horrors
yes exactly the algorithms are hungry
yeah and they will punish you if they're
not fed
but uh
yeah they punish you by having the
fruits of your previous work start to
decline
indeed
yeah so
what was that thing alan moore had that
thing you talked about steam theory
which was the idea that uh the amount of
time between the first human say the uh
the invention of the the stone axe
and then uh the baths of rome and then
the amount of time it takes to create
the same amount of stuff
you get to the point where between
1960 and 1970 human information doubles
yes everything's doubling at an
incredibly rapid rate yeah exactly so
his his idea i think this was in sort of
the early 2000s he was talking about how
by around 2013 we would go from a fluid
culture
of this sort of like river of
information and creation to so much
stuff being generated at any one moment
uh that you go from fluid to steam
uh was and it was that kurt's what was
that kurzweil's um uh an analogy who's
who who mentioned that i heard alan
moore talk about that you heard ellen
moore okay because
because kurzweil is of course famous for
the
idea that the singularity is coming as a
consequence of all of this doubling yeah
it's a i guess it's a similar thing
the idea is that you know once you're in
steam territory
anything could happen at any given
second there's things being burst like
right now someone could be about to put
something in the app store that
fundamentally changes the way we
interact
and
do stuff well yes yes well that seems to
be happening on a very regular basis i
think it's happening so rapidly that
we don't even notice it
you know i think
what's that
dating app that you swipe
into
tinder tinder is a good example of that
because tinder was a revolutionary
technology but it was buried by so many
other revolutionary technologies that
nobody even noticed that it was a
revolutionary technology
yeah
so and i think this is happening
it's happening so quickly that it's
impossible to even keep track of i mean
i work with a young team of programmers
and you know they're always looking on
the net for
new tools to help accelerate what
they're capable of doing and you know
the the library of tools out there is
well if it's not infinite it's at least
unsearchable and that also means that
each programmer
or each expert can have a whole domain
of tools that he or she is the only
person who knows anything about
which is also
very peculiar
this has happened with everything it's
happened with music
there's so many music uh it used to be
that if you wanted to make a record you
would have to go to a studio and only a
few people really got to go to studios
because they were very expensive and
there weren't even that many of them
so there's only a few people got to make
music at a higher level
just a few a decade a few day a decade
ago decade and a half ago yeah whereas
now
the thing i'm talking to you on
is the same thing that creates most of
the music you'll hear on the radio and
then within that there's this infinity
of tools and ways of of creating and
manipulating sound
uh
that each person who does it
has a unique unique stack
of things that they use that's unique to
them right
well the strange thing about what's
happened with you i would say or
one of the strange things i've noticed
i'm sure there's many strange things
that have happened with you over the
last while but
you know as
the technology for
putting music online increases in ease
and accessibility the sheer volume of
music online also increases to the same
degree and then
most people end up in the
it seems to produce uh
hyper steep
burrito distributions where
virtually everyone who puts content on
the line online
gets
pretty much zero attention that would be
especially true with music
and then a tiny fragment of people at
the very pinnacle
get
volumes of attention that are
essentially unimaginable
and you occupy kind of a strange mid
territory which
rather well which must be rather rare
you know i mean
by your numbers
i think they have to be
regarded as successful that's certainly
in terms of volume
what does it mean to you in terms of
monetization and i i ask this
actually as a technical question because
i know that monetizing creative
production is an extraordinarily
difficult thing to do
and so i'm wondering if you've had any
success at that and how you're managing
to keep body and soul together
or you pursue this
um
what would you call it
strange
pathway that's that's probably accurate
i suppose it is a strange pathway but
it's it's the only one that ever
seemed viable to me and uh for many
years it was it was
uh very difficult
i've i've you know i've been doing this
a long time and i kind of i've pioneered
a lot of the way things work now when i
first
got my first record deal i had a website
and i was releasing mixtapes online
so i was releasing these kind of
long-form projects that involved
uh songs and also cutting up bits of
spoken audio and sort of sample collages
and things
and uh i was releasing them online and
literally no one else was doing that at
that point
and when i first
worked with interscope records their
media department rang me up and asked me
how the hell i was doing everything
because they wanted to start rolling
that out to all their other artists so
that was like 2004
and uh
after i parted ways with the record
label i had to essentially kind of
create my own industry
so i was releasing mixtapes and things
and t-shirts and all that sort of stuff
streaming didn't exist at that point
we're now at the point where streaming
uh
can make money
ah well that's interesting to know but
you have to stream a lot
so it works out is it about four
thousand dollars per million streams
for example he's just looking at
streaming so you need
to be listening to a lot of your stuff
but
has a rough that's a rough percentage
man
but you think about all that you know
how many people that are in the world
and uh
and you know this insatiable hunger that
people have for for music
you know you're never going to not want
to listen to music and if you keep
giving them good music that you know
that they love and connect with they
will always listen to it and uh there's
increasing you know there's so many more
places people hear music now than
they're used to music's in everything
every video every film every experience
every avenue every instagram story ev
every
aspect of our culture has a soundtrack
and increasingly and as we strive boldly
into the future i envisage people
essentially having personalized
soundtracks everywhere they go
in every kind of instance so
right so you see a continually expanding
market
yes yes definitely and uh
yeah and there's a lot you know and
aside from like streaming there's like
there's various you know how it is
you can make a bit of money on youtube
you can sell a few t-shirts you can get
a few subscription service people
there's all
all the things together if you work hard
and you're consistent and you're good
and uh
you know you don't stop consistency is
obviously
the
fundamental then uh you can do it and
you can thrive and i i'm starting to
thrive and it feels good oh well
congratulations
that's i'm very impressed to hear that
because it seems like it seems like one
of the
world's more unlikely ways to thrive
i mean i mean
while in two ways i mean the first is
that it's very difficult to make a
career in music so just as a baseline
that that's very difficult and the
second is
well you've pioneered this
new genre which is
also
well as i said in the introduction i
don't really know what to make of it
it's this combination of metered spoken
words so there's a bit of a poetic
element to it
and then
you're carefully
selecting music to go with it and
matching the cadence of the
of the spoken word to the music
and people and people seem to be
responding to that and what what kind of
reaction are you
garnering from your
audience i mean you must get a fair bit
of correspondence
what and i mean i've read some of the
youtube comments and so forth so it
seems to me and the overwhelming
majority of those seem to be positive
which is a good thing on youtube because
that's not necessarily the case what
kind of
response are you getting from people and
what do you think you're doing for them
or to them
yeah the youtube the youtube comments is
kind of almost unheard of it's it's like
99.876
ridiculously positive
and uh i receive literally hundreds of
communications on a daily basis from
people who tell me that this is
helping them incredibly in their lives
it's i mean i imagine it's similar to
what i've heard you talking about
getting is the amount of people who
write to me saying that they got off
drugs
or uh they were they were gonna commit
suicide and things of that nature and
then the music helped them find a reason
and help them to find the strength to
get out of the trouble they were in and
things of that nature yeah that's a
that's a big deal and it's it's very
significant and specific eh to
to imagine that
the music that you're putting together
and the meaning that it conveys
has that effect both on addiction and on
suicide
yeah i mean obviously it's a substitute
well
that's probably putting it wrong
it's
it's something that's providing the
meaning that they're searching for
both through
their
addiction and
and the terrible meaning that they're
trying to escape from as a consequence
of their suicidal urges
yeah so
yeah well that's a that's a big deal and
it's it seems to me to be
psychologically very significant i mean
god only knows what psychological role
music plays in our
lives i mean
i i don't know i was going to ask you
about this is that has there been much
research done because from where i'm you
know i'm a dj
i'm out um two to five nights a week
playing music to people and seeing
firsthand the effect it has on them and
i've been experimenting with this for
years trying different combinations of
things in order to create certain
reactions my main thing i'm trying to do
is give people an incredible
transcendent experience right harry with
them
not just for the rest of the week but
for the rest of their lives but i've
experimented with combining things to
create drama to create violence to
create lust to create all sorts of
things and you can it's it's repeatable
it's it's you know it's repeatable in a
scientific experiment
capacity uh so yeah i was gonna ask you
is if you're aware of any uh no not not
really quite important well yeah i think
that
i mean it's conceivable that i'm
ignorant of the literature but i don't
think
i am because i can't see how i would
have not come across it in the research
that i've done on creativity yeah but
the study of meaning as a phenomenon
is a relatively new one i mean it
emerged to the degree that it has
emerged sort of out of the i mean in
psychology out of the literature on
happiness and well-being and of course
that's not the same thing and
um
it isn't obvious that people know how to
do the experiments properly or to take
the measurements properly
so and i think there's also a proclivity
among psychologists
to devalue
the psychological importance of cultural
products you know lots of evolutionary
psychologists for example believe that
our ability to
produce art and to produce music let's
say visual art and music
is like a secondary consequence of
something more fundamental
and i don't believe that like i i think
people would literally die without music
and drama and literature i i i can't see
that we could live i don't think we
could organize our minds
without drama and literature and i don't
think i think that music is so crucial
that it actually keeps people it's one
of the many things it's one of the few
things sorry
that actually keep people sane which is
why features so prominently and well
let's say in church in sacred
celebrations yep and and and in any
activities where people to gather
together in
in groups for anything of any
significance and you know what obviously
it's the case that if you go to a
concert
and it's well handled
there's something going on there that's
very much akin to a religious experience
yeah i don't see any difference when
it's done properly when all the people
involved
are working together uh to make it
what it could be
uh it can be more a more transcendental
experience than anything
yeah i think i think the difference
between it most religious ceremonies
that is that it actually works
[Laughter]
it does i mean i've seen people burst
into tears
when you at certain transitions
which is when you move one song into
another and uh when you're djing or when
i'm djing anyway i'm
i'm making sure that those things have a
purpose other than just playing another
song so the idea is that you're taking
people on some sort of a journey that
you're telling a story
from the beginning to the end of your
set and your set all the songs you're
playing will have a beginning in a
middle and an end and the whole
experience uh will have some sort of
transformative purpose and it will move
people in a way
and certain combinations of records the
way you'll bring in one into another you
work the way you'll sort of blend them
i've seen that make people burst into
tears right now you can see that once
just spontaneously you can see that
sometimes with particularly good chord
transitions too exactly you know there's
something so deeply satisfying about
the transformation of one pattern into
another it's
it i don't know what it well this is why
i've always been so fascinated by music
because i think there's something
unutterably deep about music i really i
really believe that it's the most
representative form of art because
i think that the world is made out of
patterns that's the best way to think of
the world and those patterns vary in
duration you know and we're always in
search for the longer duration patterns
because they're more reliable and
some of those patterns we can
let's say as tools and some we avoid as
obstacles but
and the rest we try to
intermingle harmoniously
with our actions and our thoughts so
that the whole
process turns into something that's
symphonic you know and then you go you
go to a music
festival you hear
well-arranged music in particular
because i think that's and edited music
well it all matters the melodic
composition in the words all of that
matters but to hear it
well written and well edited and well
arranged
speaks to you about how
the entire structure
the entire structure of being
could be arranged and also is
fortunately arranged those rare times
where
everything comes together for you
and so people need that experience man
it it reminds them of
the potential harmony
that
that things can attain and that's that's
not optional especially if you're in a
chaotic state
it's the truth of it's i think it's the
truth
of everything
and uh that community it's what is it
stevie wonder said music is the language
we all speak
something we all understand and no
that's that's true across the world and
i've seen that it's interesting how
music will will change from place to
place but the fundamental aspects of it
are the same and the fundamental
need for it is the same yeah it's
absolutely fascinating that there's so
much there's as many variations as there
are languages but we can understand all
of them i mean you know
our language has a musical element right
if you listen to someone who's an
interesting speaker there's a lot of
melody in their
speech
patterns this is why i first made uh a
sample jew because i heard the melody
and something he was saying and i could
instantly hear what the song was around
it there was a rhythm in it there was a
melody in it the whole thing and uh
every individual
has that and it's often quite radically
different even within the same language
it's interesting different languages
have different
melodies and therefore if you listen to
uh french music the actual melodies and
music
are similar to the shape of the the
voice the vocal sounds
of the actual language
uh this same with mexican same with
english so on and so forth so like
melodies within music of cultures are
informed very much by the the language
that people speak
i wonder what makes english particularly
appropriate by all appearances for rock
and roll
yes is it is it it's a fairly
consonant heavy language so maybe that
has something to do with it there's a
like it isn't it hasn't got that same
vowel like sing song that
asian languages often have so it's got a
bit more of a beat like harshness
but like rock doesn't seem to work very
well in french germans managed to pull
it off now and then but not that often
it's really remarkably an english
experience altogether and that's a great
thing
i think this is why hip-hop has taken
over the world
hip-hop is now the dominant
genre
everywhere
pretty much everywhere and uh
i spend a fair bit of my time
researching music on a weekly basis as a
part of my job
and uh
listening to music in different
countries and and hip-hop has
essentially taken over the whole world
and hip-hop exists
uh
in every language i've looked into
and it works
in every language
and uh there's multiple reasons for that
but just the thing we're talking about
is interesting but the sort of the shape
like french sounds fantastic on rap
far more so than uh on say rock i don't
know that's subjective mm-hmm
you know the english in the english
accent we do a lot of uh small sounds
then elongated sounds
which um
what's that called the uh scottish snap
the sky which is uh
a thing that's in a lot of rap these
days it's like this type thing is a did
it
kind of goes in and out
the sound you're hearing a lot in old
sort of folk music rock and roll is
interesting because it's almost a
perfect combination
of uh
of european folk and
african
jazz and and traditional music right
right yeah right yeah coming out there's
been some recent little skirmishes of
people accusing say ariana grande of
cultural appropriation to using a rap
rhythm
in the cadence of her singing but that
rhythm is actually traced back to
scotland
right well one of the things that we
should agree on right
off the bat is that we don't have to pay
any attention to anyone who ever dares
to say anything about cultural
appropriation
given that absolute necessity of trading
these modes of communication across the
world and the unbelievable utility that
that's had and and even the idea that
it's a form of
theft in terms of its motivation is so
entirely specious because most of the
time it's
rooted in what i would regard as
tremendous admiration it's not like the
rolling stones were massive fans of the
of the black blues artists from the us
you know i mean they were doing
everything they could to imitate them
yeah so
this is another one of this is one of
another another one of the reasons why
hip-hop has taken over the world and
could be considered the ultimate art
form or maybe ultimate musical art form
uh because it takes from everything
within to itself to make something
and that's the reason there hasn't been
a new musical genre a new sort of
specific
like
tentpole musical genre uh since hip-hop
yeah yeah
yeah
right right and that's actually getting
to be quite a while ago now yeah it was
about it was the 70s
and so what happened was you had and
it's really amazing how hip-hop was born
hip-hop was born because there was some
rioting in new york
and uh some poor people managed to get
their hands on some quite good sound
equipment
and start throwing parties with it and
uh one of them worked out a way of
playing the same record
on two turntables at a slightly
different part of the record on each
side so he could create a loop
over which
from the record over which somebody
could rap tell the story hype up the
crowd therein it was born uh take
from another piece of existing music or
another piece of existing idea and you
know they were sampling european
dance they were sampling craft work and
they were sampling like weird folk stuff
and there was you know they were
sampling james brown they were sampling
from everywhere
hip-hop was taken from every
bit of the existing music musical
multiverse
and then people could talk about
anything they could talk about their
real experiences they could talk about
their fantasies they could talk about
their fears
i remember chuck d once saying that the
the core story in hip-hop was could be
boiled down to as simple as
uh
i am like i exist
like the the protest of it or the the
call of the story is just like i i exist
i'm here and then the music
is is as culturally appropriative as
possible they took from everywhere
and without if they hadn't done that it
wouldn't exist and if you suddenly start
telling people no you can't do that
anymore then uh you're going to end up
with a sort of very dull well the other
thing that awful
if
if you look at it again from a
psychological perspective is that
for me to understand you
i have to imitate you
that's the ground of understanding it's
not like i listen to what you say and
then
think about it and then
react although i do that to some degree
it's that i watch you
i look at what you're looking at i
listen to the cadence of your voice you
know i adjust my body so that it's in
accordance with yours
if we're having a real conversation i
have to we have to
create a space between us that's a
consequence of a mutual imitation
even changing the way that we speak
because i'm going to adjust the way i
speak to the way you speak and vice
versa or we're not going to have a
conversation
we have to enter into the same space to
use a terrible cliche but all of that's
a consequence of
deep deep and often unconscious and
implicit imitation and to
say that
cultural appropriation is a mistake is
to deny people the ability to deeply
imagine each other you know because
there are conversations going on now
that a man should never write a woman's
role or a white person should never
write a black person's role it's like
well all you're doing is forbidding
the creator
to
project him or herself into the
landscape of that other person and try
to and try to truly no it's not just
empathy it's way deeper than empathy to
try to
live out their experience to the best of
their imaginative ability in a deep way
and maybe one that can be communicated
with other people you know like
maybe a white guy who writes about black
experience
and he's careful about it
um
can bridge a gap that no other person
can bridge and even though it might not
be a hundred percent accurate and
not to say that biography itself or
autobiography itself is ever 100
accurate it's the best we can do with
regards to climbing inside someone
else's skull and
and attempting to
truly
walk a mile in their shoes let's say you
know i read a great book by a woman
named
margaret lawrence who's a very
underrated canadian author and she wrote
a book called the stone angel which was
about a about an 88 year old woman i
think an elderly elderly woman
and
and margaret lawrence was not that age
when she wrote the book and i certainly
wasn't an 88 year old woman when i wrote
it and i found it profoundly affecting
like it was the first time in my life
that i had really understood that
you're the same
when you're
old you know like
very much of you is like you were when
you were 30 or 40 it's just that
well you've started to deteriorate
physiologically and
and sometimes
but not always psychologically but
all of the emotions and
all of the perceptions and the desires
and longings and the doubts and all of
that are are there just as powerfully
and
i don't think i
would have understood that until i was
much much older
had
i not had the uh
the good fortune of encountering that
book
so
i i think that the people who are
discussing cultural appropriation i
truly believe that they hate art because
that that is art man that's
take from the best of everything
and and see if you can go one step
farther
yeah
they just haven't thought it through
because the end result of that is that
uh you can only write
basically you only have uh autobiography
you couldn't have a comic book unless it
was written by a team of 30 people if it
contained 30 characters it's it's it
means putting everyone into back into
their little boxes
and not allowed to integrate with the
world it means that no one right exactly
does
and it means that r dies
well i think that's the point of the
complaint is that that there's a true
hatred for art that lurks underneath
that and a desire for it to be replaced
by a kind of propaganda i mean even if
you wrote autobiography you wouldn't be
able to write about anyone else
yes exactly you know it's there's a lot
of people complaining about modern art
and uh
you know the assault on the assault on
beauty but this war on beauty this kind
of rejection of of uh skill
and uh transcended obviously
transcendent greatness uh in lieu of
kind of like ugly things that remind us
of that let me ask you about the people
that you've chosen
to to
feature in your
meet is it best referred to as meaning
wave or as lo-fi and what what do you
what's the difference
well yeah meaning wave is as what this
genre of music i'm working on has come
to be known as
and it is the combination as you put of
the uh the meaning
of the meaningful speech with uh wave
music wave music
is uh
lo-fi
uh it's trap it's vapor trap it's cloud
cloud giraffe it's a bunch of different
things uh but they share a common
aesthetic vapor wave things of that
nature which is uh amusingly a
postmodern art form uh low-fi just means
low fidelity
so
i've always made lo-fi because when i
first started making hip-hop uh it
sounded quite bad because i didn't know
what i was doing so it was quite low low
quality
low fire just means uh
you know maybe there's some record
crackle maybe you've uh
it's not the most polish sounding thing
it's not top i see radio it's it's not
i've been considering uh
doing another project called hi-fi which
goes in the exact opposite direction and
just goes pristine clean
what have you but anyway so lo-fi is
that meaning wave is where i took
those musical forms and combined them
with with speech and then did you see
some advantages in the lo-fi approach
apart from its initial technical
simplicity
i've always loved that sound i've always
loved warm analog crackly sounds
i've always loved hip-hop well li-fi
hip-hop is really it's just hip-hop
instrumentals with uh without an
emphasis on high-tech production
um
so it means that so you think it's do
you think it's more
comforting and welcoming to people i
mean i've often been in buildings you
know like modern buildings that are so
perfect that the only thing that
shouldn't be there is you
indeed yeah that is it's a creepy
feeling yeah it is it is a creepy
feeling because like there's some degree
of
imperfection that seems to be need or
age
warmness
well we have this happen with music so
technology is what uh drives music
always the reason that music sounds like
it does currently
uh a lot of it is
to do with technology there's a drum kit
that's used on almost all music you'll
hear on the radio which is the 808 kit
and that's been uh kind of dominated
music for the past 10 to 20 years and
the reason for that is because it sounds
really as good coming out of a telephone
as it does a club system
and uh the drum kits they were using
before that just don't pop out of a
phone in the same way you can't really
hear them uh
so until phones can more accurately
accurately reproduce low end that drum
kit will remain very popular but what
happened with music anyway we saw it as
the 80 technology came in computers came
in synthesizers came in and it started
getting really really clean sounding
like really really clean and then as
people started working within computers
and the music oftentimes the music would
never leave the computer it'd be made on
a mac it'd go through some fiber optic
cables into someone else's mac or into
another phone
and uh it was that
became that kind of cleanliness you were
talking about that kind of sterilized
thing and uh lo-fi reintroduces
real-world analog elements to the thing
which brings uh a humanity and a
nostalgia
and a sort of tactile feeling the uh
music
had started to lose which i think is why
people yeah well there's something about
analog instruments that that have a
singing quality
that the electronic instruments even at
the highest end lock like i notice when
i'm playing the piano which i'm not very
good at but
i can do at least to some degree
if i play an electronic piano
every note is okay and all the chords
are okay but i can't get the whole
instrument to sing
and then like if the whole instrument is
singing because of
endless resonance then you can start to
overlay the chords on the resonance and
and
it it makes the entire experience much
richer and deeper and that seems to me a
very to be a very hard thing to
duplicate on electronic instruments
yeah
uh i think you know the
the uh limitless potential
that technology has bought us is a
wonderful wonderful thing but at the
same time we don't want to be throwing
out the proverbial baby with through
proverbial bathwater and losing that
foundational quality so i think kind of
a situation where you can have aspects
of both working together harmoniously is
uh
optimal that's what i've been that's
what i've been trying to do uh so you
get some of the messy complexity of
analog with the
perfection and and and like endless
possibility of electronic yeah there's
stuff you can do with electronic that
you cannot do with with analog and
physical i can uh i can sample
you playing the piano and then i could
go in there and if i wanted i could go
in and change a chord
i could go in there and get the notes
separated and move one of them around
just to slightly change the chord
there's stuff we can do
which blows my mind now there's things
coming out every week ai has started
well machine learning they call it ai
has started to come into music
production and uh there's some
incredibly exciting things happening in
that area
uh but the trick is as always is not to
get carried away with these things and
lose the foundational aspects
uh
when in you know when we embrace these
things right yeah well i noticed the
other day that google had this little
game on its
search page where you could go and
type in a simple melody
on a note
on a
staff that they had provided
and that it would convert it to
a bach analog
by analyzing 400 different bach pieces
and then determining how it would be
corded and how it would progress
you know and it was difficult to
evaluate because it was very short and
the fidelity was relatively low but
but
it's pretty damn impressive that an ai
system can go and evaluate 400 pieces of
box music
and then
rewrite something that has the same
spirit
based on a separate melody in a matter
of seconds
and i mean the thing about all this new
technology is that barring catastrophe
bar
good time for everything to blur i would
say
barring catastrophe it's all brand new
and it's going to be so much better in
20 years that we can't even imagine it
you know because you kind of think well
this is a new technology and you think
well it's new it's like and and it's
like finished in some sense and
we're we're so much at the infancy of
this electronic revolution that it's
almost impossible to even imagine
i'm very very excited about
where we will be in 20 years just based
off of watching my six-year-old son
hercules play minecraft with his best
friend quincy who lives in canada
and uh
these little these little kids
creating these galaxies creating these
huge worlds create like down from the
smallest details of building little
houses and putting beds in them and
looking in the drawers down to zooming
out and creating like whole environments
and things
and uh and working together and like you
know quincy is very good at this kind of
thinking and this kind of stuff and
hercules is very good at a different
kind of thing and they just harmoniously
come together to create this stuff
within these these super computers the
size of a paperback right
general worlds yeah and a generation
who've grown up with that just being
default just expecting to be able to
imagine a thing and make it so
you know when we were when i was a
little kid i would sort i would draw
comics and things of that nature and i
would imagine things and i would draw
them and they would look a bit like i
imagined you know and i practiced
drawing and i got pretty good at it i
could never
get out exactly what i was thinking
you'd get an idea um
you know these kids can
really imagine vast vast things and and
look at them and see if they work and
they go this doesn't work i will destroy
that and do another thing and so on and
so forth so when these
kids uh 20
what the hell are they going to do
this is
a generation uh
whose imagination whose expectation of
being able to create what they imagine
has no limits on it a generation who
from as long as they could remember had
all had a super computer that was the
most powerful movie studio
in existence the most powerful recording
studio a magazine
you know they can publish they can talk
to anyone in the world they can
publish to anyone in the world they
don't have limits on their clients no no
everybody's a media powerhouse
but also a problem-solving powerhouse in
a way and when they work together that's
what's really interesting is
kids playing minecraft together
they don't need to say okay you're good
at this you do that they just work it
out and then do it and they go at a
problem and they fix it
and uh yeah well i'm just
really excited about what they're going
to do
do you and you look and watch what he
creates
yes and it's it's it's beautiful
it's beautiful it's like you know
sistine chapels like you zoom out and
it's fractals and you zoom in and it's
like you've made a little house for his
buddy or he's made a statue of his
friend or he's built a roller coaster or
whatever it is
and then he'll set it all on fire or
something he'll become an angry god and
he'll
throw lava at the thing
but uh
yeah you know because
so many barriers
the
previous generations had are evaporating
and you have that you have you know the
barriers of education or the barriers
like i was talking about earlier
you only used to be able to have 12 rock
stars at once because there were only 12
covers of rolling stone
right
you know so uh that's why uh
michael jackson
tried to get prince destroyed
or was it yeah it was because you know
it's like well there's only oh no this
yeah first there was that and then they
kind of like joined forces against uh
terence trent derby
according to terence tran derby terence
trent derby uh
was a threat because he was like a third
black guy and you're only allowed and at
that point there was statistically only
room for two black guys because of the
amount of covers of rolling stone
right right there's some limiting factor
yeah but that doesn't exist anymore that
doesn't exist anymore there's uh you
nowadays you can be a cult person like
say young lean who's a swedish rapper
that mainstream people wouldn't know of
but everything he releases gets millions
of streams and views and he can tour the
world and live come to comfortably
forever
uh you know the barriers for uh
education you can learn everything you
can learn online right so now you have
now you have niche celebrities
yeah
it's very strange things
yes because you you wouldn't expect that
to be a possibility but with the massive
i mean i think there's two and a half
billion people on youtube and
god only knows what the total reach of
the podcast networks are
and so
you can have a pretty sizable following
on any of those platforms and be
invisible to the majority of the people
who are on them
yes
it's it's yeah it's an incredible thing
you know this is why they they they hate
pewdiepie
god bless him uh
pewdiepie it's amazing that you have a
situation where
the biggest person on the biggest online
uh broadcasting platform
is somehow underground an
anti-establishment
yeah
well i think it's i think i think it's
evidence that this new media
world is
underground and anti-establishment in in
the most profound possible way
like i can't i can't see how
broadcast television can possibly
survive youtube no it's dead and this is
another reason i'm very excited about
this generation because not only is this
generation got this uh minecraft
limitless potential actualization
incredible computer skills coding skills
he's learning to code young hercules six
years old just so that he can create
portals in minecraft and open a portal
to another dimension the fact that he's
interested in opening portals to other
dimensions and has that as a thing in
his vocabulary is incredible but right
combine that with uh this complete
disdain for uh you know mainstream media
or uh
or those sorts of those sorts of systems
uh
it's like what is gonna happen what are
they gonna do
i guess one question that that raises
for me is
what is it that's going to hold us
together
you know i mean
one of the things and this might just be
the
what would you call it
nostalgia
of someone who's old enough to have a
certain amount of nostalgia
i mean with the limited broadcast means
that we had
when i grew up you know i had three
television channels when i grew up at
least to begin with and one of them was
in french so it didn't really count
had a limited number of radio stations
and so forth and newspapers there was a
there was a
continually emergent consensus about
what constituted
the real
you know in the social and political
realm at least and even in the physical
world to some degree
and part of that i think was that
many of those venues
of communication were actually very
carefully vetted and edited you know and
i would say time magazine would would
have fallen into that category because
it was quite a magazine in its heyday
you know a quarter of an inch thick and
almost
almost nothing but solid text very
carefully written
and you could quibble about the
biases and accuracy of the reporters but
they seem to be
professionals and they seem to be well
supervised and
well regulated and of course there's
danger in over supervision and hyper
regulation but
what seems to happen now is that
it's almost possible
and maybe this is what the
post-modernists were
imagining you know in some sense or
intuiting
that we were entering a world where
there would be so many different
interpretations of what was real that
virtually everyone could extract out
from the
endless stream of
communication
that
construction of the world that seemed to
suit them best for better or worse
and there's a fragmentation that goes
along with that that seems to me to be
well maybe dangerous is it dangerous
enough to be driving some of the
nihilism that seems evident and some of
the ideological rigidity
you know nihilism was uh
an unavoidable byproduct of of the line
of questioning that humans were going
down but i think they're starting to
come out of that and that's another
thing in this uh
this new generation i'm seeing is
a uh
a swing back against nihilism
yeah you think and so yeah well that
would account for the popularity of the
meaning wave and so
what what why do you
what makes you confident in that i mean
i'm i'm hoping very much that you're
correct in your assumption but what
makes you confident in that well i think
it's historically visible
that we always you always see this
people always react against their
parents and so on and so forth there's
always that pendulum swing backward and
forward
it's like as you said so with these
patterns an observable pattern which
i've been aware of since uh since i was
a kid
uh is the seven year cycle from uh punk
to psychedelia
which swings backwards and forwards
like a ticking clock
uh and has done my whole life
and uh
so that's sort of like a swing between
complexity and simplicity or all right
think about it there's plexiglas rawness
yeah well i mean it's a cul it's a
cultural phenomenon but everything
a great deal of what occurs is
downstream from culture
uh so if you think the sort of late 90s
sorry the late 80s
we had a summer of love of sorts we had
a hippie period acid house music was
going people were dressing in bright
colors uh things were all combining
together
rap and dance and all these things and
people were taking mdma
and acid and stuff of that nature rape
culture was a big thing then uh it swung
back into uh
punky nihilisticness and this happens in
the colors people wear what people dress
somebody went into nirvana
talking about killing like misery and it
went into uh
brit pop in the uk
things became more conservative in this
and then sonics and their and the
clothes stars were people wearing and
then it went uh psychedelic again
uh to the point i really i was thinking
about this earlier i was like oh my god
they actually legalized mushrooms in
london at the year i calculated to be
the peak of that particular seven year
psychedelic cycle then it swung back
again music went into emo
um
then it went back again the more recent
one 2013 was the peak of the more recent
psychedelic thing
uh
we had odd futures the biggest rap group
people wearing tie-dye uh everyone drugs
wise it was uh molly which is
mdma again then it swung back into
nihilism and it's like it's kind of like
the uh you know there's pirate ship
rights
it's like a pirate boat and you pull up
and you see it and then you go chew him
down and he did that in 2013 and then
suddenly
the drug had switched to xanax it was
all downers
uh
punk
and goth stuff became the kind of
cultural signpost colors went into black
fonts went into gothic
the conspiracy culture went from talking
about aliens to uh complaining about
feminism and all those people that were
interested in psychedelic out there
staffed up until 2013 was suddenly not
anymore and now it's starting to swing
back in the other direction
again and uh but this time because we're
all networked so much at this point the
whole psychedelic thing is going to be a
lot more psychedelic and a lot more
powerful and have a lot more of a
lasting impact
i believe
so you know now you've picked
ellen watts and joker and terence
mckenna and david foster wallace and
elon musk and
like
how do you select the people
from whom you derive your meaning wave
albums and tracks
well we're talking it's
looking at the puzzle from a different
angle
which is valid which is useful so it's
like i used to make music wherein i
would rap
and sing so i was rapping and singing
and then i got to a point where i
realized that i didn't yet know enough
to
make an album about what i wanted to
make an album about
my first album was about was called when
we were young and it was about being a
kid and my second album was about uh
the life equation was about kind of
uh being not a kid and interface
interfacing with the world the third
album
what that needed to be about i didn't
know enough yet
and then i started listening to lots of
people and listening to their position
their perspectives on things and
you know say between you and alan watts
you're you're in a way doing what alan
watts did for eastern culture for
western culture
and it's in a funny way because it's
like you have a generation or two
that don't have knowledge of these
fundamental aspects of sort of western
culture it was sort of stolen from them
and you've come along and you're
re-introducing that to people in a
foundational fashion and alan watts did
a similar thing but with uh eastern
ideas terence mckenna talks about a lot
of the same stuff you talk about but
from a specific angle a different angle
to the way you look
and it's also i think of it in
archetypes
in a way and you say someone like jocko
willink
is the warrior perhaps
and that's his his is a very very
necessary perspective
at this point it's similar in ways to
yours it has aspects of sort of
discipline and stuff of that nature but
in a you know in a much he he's looking
at a very specific site
uh at which he is expert i just thought
it would be this incredible powerful
thing if you could take people
somebody's thought about a specific
thing for 30 years
and make that into pot music that people
could listen to in the gym or in the
shower or wherever they were and they
could really really bring it into their
lives you're not necessarily going to
listen to a podcast more than once even
a really really good one but if i take
the
what i
think of the most interesting or best
bits of a podcast and turn them into a
pop song you could listen to that 100
times
and it could
get in and you could really think about
it and you could really integrate it
into your life or integrate the the bits
of it
that are useful to you
yeah well i mean that that's how people
learned historically right they set
poetry to music and
listen to it over and over and
that made it stick
this is so
the pre the oral tradition indeed
because the first thing i did was when i
i left school when i was 16 but my last
exams
the revision i did for them involved me
just reading my revision notes over
ambient music
in a cassette recorder and then playing
it when i went to sleep
which is which is i guess the first
meaning wave that i mean
right right
but yeah this is what we've been doing
for thousands of years
yeah well it's a lot easier to remember
something if it's presented in a
multi-modal way right so you have the
words you have the rhythm you have the
rhyming
and you have the music i mean so
basically you're remembering it along
five dimensions at the same time instead
of just trying to extract out the
abstract semantic meaning and and store
that which is that's very effortful you
know and i'm not even sure you can do it
without going through those first
stages
which stages
well the stages of of rhythm and oh yeah
yeah and memorization and you know i i
don't know how well you have to know
something from the perspective of
memorization let's say before you can
start to really think about it deeply
and to transform it your own way
this is it you know people used to
remember whole books right yeah people
would be walking around with volumes and
volumes of poetry and books in their
heads and they'd be able to like you
know just whip it out i mean it's just
people used to i mean even in my
lifetime people had
catalogues of jokes
and stories
right ready
to throw out there in a pub conversation
or whatever it was
and uh that seems to be declining
somewhat it's one of the
the unfortunate results of this
wonderful technology yes yes well we
seem to externalize everything you know
yeah because we can put everything in
the cloud now so we don't need to save
it on our hard drive right right and it
makes you it makes you wonder
what there is that's in you i saw this
funny new yorker cartoon a while back
where
a man came out with a fact of some sort
and his wife says well do you know that
or do you just google know it
yeah and and there's a big difference
between
having a fact at your disposal because
you can find it in library and actually
having that fact
in your cognitive toolbox so that you
can use it
actively in your life
and you know it's it's certainly been
unbelievably useful for me to
create and remember a bank of stories
and it makes you a much more much much
more effective communicator and a much
better thinker like
when i was a kid in grade 8 or grade 9
you know and we were asked to memorize
poetry i always felt that was such a
waste of time that
but it was already written down in a
book
what good
did it do for me to be able
to to recite it
and
you know then i met a guy
years ago years later
who was an undergraduate and uh a
remarkable person
genius and rather unstable unfortunately
so i don't think he ever amounted to
much but
one of the things he could do was
declaim large sections of shakespeare at
a moment's notice
apropos
and it was unbelievably impressive like
you know when he would start it
everybody in the room would fall silent
and like and he was very good at it you
know he he wasn't embarrassing himself
by
bursting into this
into this old english prose it was
a real accomplishment and that was the
first time that i saw
how empty
modern people were in some sense because
they
don't have that interiorized
verbal culture you know now it's not
sure it's not clear that in more archaic
societies everybody had that either
from what i've understood it was the
shamanic types that were the vast
repository of the entire oral tradition
but
people had their stories and
um
well you need to have your story so i
don't know what it is exactly that we're
going to substitute for that
yeah well you know we're in a we're
as you said this has just begun
we're still you know in in sort of
zooming out terms we're still we're
still in in utero
yes
we've yet to be born and i think we're i
think we're coming close to being born
uh which is why
uh
everything is the way it is and it's
such a such a heightened it's just an
incredible period of history to exist in
at this point you know you could admit
you could have been born at any time and
for most of human history you'd have
been suffering away unless you were some
kind of lord and even then you'd have
had wooden teeth if you were really
lucky
right and they didn't fit very well
no he's like jesus christ imagine
there's a thing hercules said the good
thing about having kids as i'm sure you
know is they um obviously you know is
they just say really really smart things
that make you think and hercules there's
a thing in minecraft where you have uh
survival mode and creative mode in
survival mode
uh
night time comes and the monsters come
out to get you and you have to go hide
in your house and hope that the monsters
don't get you and uh there are
limitations on you and in creative mode
there aren't these limitations and you
can fly and you can build and play and
hercules just it just turns around to me
not seemingly inspired by anything that
just happened i said dad i wish it could
be creative mode in real life just for
one day because really we're in survival
mode and we have to eat and we have to
work and die it goes i would just love
it to be creative mode and just fly into
the sky and play just for one day
and i thought what a beautiful thing and
then i thought but hang on this is
actually what we're doing right about a
week later i thought that and i was like
this is actually what we're doing as a
species for the first time
a vast proportion of us aren't spending
all of our time just trying to stay
alive we're in creative mode
yes at least some of the time and that's
something to be very
very grateful for because i think that's
right
well it's unbelievably new it's it's
crazily new
i mean people
god who knows say
hopefully it leads to everybody playing
together nicely so that we can build a
better world
you know and i would say
there's a reasonable amount of evidence
that that's occurring i mean
for all of its
catastrophic problems the internet works
pretty well
i mean it it's given us a tremendous
plethora of gifts even something you
know
i'm not saying trivial because it's not
but taken for granted as google maps has
had a profound effect on the way people
live you're never lost anymore
and it's enabled technologies like uber
which i think uber is a wonderful
technology i think the fact that now
anybody who's unemployed but has a
functional vehicle can almost
immediately find a way to make 500 or a
thousand dollars in a week or a week and
a half is an absolute bloody miracle i
mean
it
i might be wrong about this but it seems
like
that kind of poverty
you know barring inability to drive and
other catastrophes that kind of poverty
where
you're backed in a corner you're just
screwed there's nothing you can do about
it that's
uber seems to have made a lot of that
disappear it's like hey man you can't
make a fortune but
you can make enough to get yourself out
of a tight spot and it's actually a
pretty pleasant
experience like i like taking ubers
there's no financial transaction people
are almost always polite you know
exactly where the car is going to be
like
i don't know
i think
i think it's been a really good thing
so and it's of course only one of
god
one of an infinity of miracles that are
unfolding before us like
like firecrackers every given second
is yes
there's on that thing you know if you if
you
there are so many ways to make money now
if if you're completely skillless you
can go
on let go of facebook garyvee talks
about this sort of stuff a lot uh you
know you can people are giving away
chairs i don't want this chair anymore
you go yeah yeah then you sell it for
ten dollars you do that all day you can
you can make hundreds of dollars in a
day you don't have to have any skills
whatsoever
they can if you do have skills there's a
million ways for you to make money and
if you don't have skills there's a
million ways for you to get those skills
there are 12 year olds on youtube who
will show you how to do everything yeah
and i and i love those 12 year olds and
i use them all the time right right yeah
good for those 12 year olds right no
well absolutely well and you get these
old guys down in like the southern us
who are like old plumbers or you know
they've got some specialty that they're
good at and they'll
grab their iphone roughly and
just
gruffly
film themselves fixing something say oh
that's how you fix that
you know and it's it's so it's such an
interesting
manifestation of altruism you know and
an indication
i mean people obviously like the
attention that their videos
garner and i think that's perfectly
reasonable because it's a form of
indication that what you're doing is
valuable no i mean there's an ego
element to it but the ego element is in
fact the fact that what you're doing is
valuable
and it's so cool that people will take
the extra effort
like i was installing a stereo in this
old car of mine a while back and you
know it
it was a pretty old car like 11 or 12
years and
somebody had put up a video about how to
install the stereo in the car and
i would have never figured out that
specific car yeah i would have never
figured it out because there was hidden
screws and all sorts of weird things
that
needed to be
known
and
the guy didn't have to do it
you know it was just good to do it and
it certainly saved me a lot of time and
energy so that was quite
that was quite wonderful it would be
really something if
part of what the coming technological
revolution enabled us to do would be to
play
and to play more effectively in a way
that would translate into real world
results you know and
it is it's conceivable that that's one
of the consequences
i mean all these people that are
learning to code and learning to use
computers in a sophisticated way i mean
god they're just you know you know the
chinese graduate more engineers every
year than the americans have engineers
what's this other thing that's coming
down the pipeline is this babelfish
thing
uh you know this translation technology
which is already bloody good
but in a few years it's going to be
seamless
yeah i will be able to talk to you and
you will be speaking a different
language shall we say
uh
and instantly that will be translated to
me and i'll be able to have a
conversation with you in my language and
we'll understand each other certainly
means that twitter opens up to china
and well i mean government's allowing
but said but you know i mean like these
sorts of uh current online
community experiences we have open up to
the world and it also means that trade
opens up to the world and it also means
all that information you're talking
about opens up to the world because now
you don't just watch the video of the
guy in ohio you watch the video with the
guy in tokyo or wherever right yeah you
understand it and suddenly the sum of
human
knowledge and experience and usefulness
is shared with everybody right
right yes it's quite it's quite well
unfortunately at the same time the the
sum of human
foolishness and and impulsivity as well
which is
you know i guess par for the course but
something that we're trying to
desperately learn how to manage
i'm hey uh just out of curiosity
how long would it take you to queue up
42 rules for life how do you mean i was
in stop playing it yeah
would this be a good time
yeah why not why not dj pizzas let's do
it man let's play some of it
tell the truth
or at least don't lie don't lie
[Music]
do not do things that you hate
act so that you can tell the truth
about how you act
[Music]
pursue what is meaningful
not
what is expedient
if you have to choose
[Music]
be the one who does things
instead of the one
who is seen to do things
pay attention
assume that the person you were
listening to
might know something you need to know
listen to them hard enough so that they
will share it with you
plan and work diligently to maintain the
romance
in your relationships
[Music]
be careful who you share good news with
be careful
do you share bad news with
remember
that what you do not yet know
is more important
than what you already know
be grateful
[Music]
in spite of your suffering
what's been the most exciting project
that you've embarked on so far do you
think what what's been the most
gratifying project is that a reasonable
question that's a reasonable question
but the answer is that each one
is more exciting and gratifying than the
last
ah which ties into this hyper
productivity
uh staying in the zone and refusing to
leave experiment because it compounds
is that the right word it just
yeah
it just gets more and more intense and
uh and better and exciting
there are synchronicities just in that
just keep popping up and popping up and
becoming myriad and ridiculous
uh and i've taken i've taken
synchronicities to be as signposts is
what i'm treating those as malcolm x
said that when you spot synchronicities
you're walking with allah
grant morrison always said it was the
first step to becoming a
a successful chaos magician was noticing
those synchronicities and paying
attention so i treat those things and
they're just every project i do there's
more and more and more of that as i keep
in this thing and sort of don't stop
the last one i did which was clockwork
elves which was the terence mckenna
project i just meant to do one song i'd
finish the allen watts album
i was like i'm going to do this one
terence mckenna song about his clockwork
elves thing this is interesting it ties
into something that watts was talking
about
and um
i sort of came out of a daze
at sort of three in the morning and i'd
made an album
and it was almost like i didn't do it
it's like and then i've been thinking
about this quite a lot
there's a thing in uh japanese anime you
see a lot these uh these met these mecca
suits which are like these giant robot
suits and then humans sort of pilot them
but they're these amazing suits and a
human can get in that and they can you
can destroy a city or
you know whatever it is kind of feel
that when you're doing this stuff
optimizing yourself in this fashion
um becoming really really good
at a thing becoming really proficient
cutting out areas of wastefulness uh
becoming this finely tuned machine
at that point you then sort of hand the
keys to god
as it were
stevie wonder always said that he didn't
write his songs he kind of opened
himself up and god wrote them through
well you know you you develop such a
body of expertise now in relationship to
this
so much of what you do has become
automatized you know and i don't mean
that in a bad way i mean that you've
developed expert circuitry for all sorts
of pieces of it and
as you become better at something
it's necessary to stand back
increasingly and let what you already
know
you let what you already know dominate
you and take you over and and then you
add a creative bend and twist here and
there
to
stop it from being merely wrote
you know like someone do that he's great
at playing a cello you know they have
every technique down perfectly but they
bend and twist each note
consciously to to add something new to
it when you hit that zone
it does mean that
well everything that you've worked out
to that point is starting to run
automatically and there is an experience
of
harmony i would say with
with deeper parts of being when that
occurs and it's not surprising because
if you've put that circuitry together
honestly and diligently and courageously
then it should be functioning properly
and towards the good
and so when you're in the throes of that
if you're fortunate then there should be
almost nothing about that that isn't
good
that's that's why that's partly why
character is so important you know what
people don't understand or or they're
not taught is that
you genuinely become what you practice
and not and not at some trivial level i
mean it's built into you
biologically
as well as spiritually
yeah it's it's uh
it's terrifying
you go through life
and uh the reason one of the reasons
life feels like it's speeding up is
because you turn things into habits
right
and then your brain kind of fast
forwards past the habit yeah you're
going the same route to work every day
your brain will fast forward through
that thing unless something different
happens so a lot of times people feel
life is speeding up because they've just
turned so much stuff into habit so you
have to be really careful about what you
are allowed to become habit and you have
to keep checking on what your habits are
because at the same time you want to
turn useful things into habits right
yeah well that's part of it that's part
of the tremendous difficulty of the
balance between order and chaos exactly
you know i mean because order does
become
invisible
and unconscious and
with the proclivity to become tyrannical
and sterile but it's absolutely
necessary because it makes you
efficient and allows you to do
things that need to be done more than
once with a high degree of accuracy and
and and expertise
but then there's that
ad mixture of the new that has to
well that's what that's what again i
think that's what music signifies
because
there's a fair bit of repetition in all
music
and that gives you a baseline
expectation of what's going to happen
you know so
you're playing a game
along with the musician and you both
basically know the rules but what you're
hoping that the musician will do is
break the rules at least to some degree
in some way that
shocks you a bit and keeps you
interested and
allows you to understand new
possibilities
that's exactly what makes a great dj set
you want to have the right the right
balance of
stuff that a person knows and makes them
feel good and want to dance but then
something that sort of shocks them and
surprises them and takes them somewhere
they weren't quite expecting
there's this thing i've been doing
recently where i i've forced myself to
play fifty percent stuff i haven't
played before
or way i haven't played before because i
i found at one point i'd found myself
sort of
falling into a like i knew all so many
things that worked it was really easy
for me to unleash these combinations
of things that work like in a fighting
game you like press combine these
various moves and you have like you
unleash like a series of
fighting moves and you can knock the
person out and i could do that very very
easily
but uh the really exciting things to do
and the really useful to do things to do
is to keep coming up with new ones and
make sure about half of what you're
doing is in their area of danger
and the creation of something new which
because that's what leads to those
moments where the hairs stand up on
right right yeah well you have to have
that element of i would say surprise but
also of the potential for failure
exactly right because i mean i noticed
this
with my lectures is that
you know before i go out and do a
lecture
i always have
i spend about an hour
meditating
although i hate to use that word but it
is what i'm doing
trying to
figure out what problem i'm trying to
address and then trying to walk my way
through this story that would enable me
to explore that problem but then i
always have about five minutes of sheer
terror
about the fact that it might not work
like i might not get the problem
formulated properly and i might not get
through the story and come up with uh
the point because you know the talk
should have a point
there should be a conclusion or perhaps
multiple conclusions but at least one
conclusion
and
because i
mix enough of what's new in each lecture
it isn't obvious to me that that's
necessarily going to happen now i've
been fortunate so far and
it's happened each time i've lectured
publicly which is how many times now oh
well for the 12 rules for life tour it's
150 cities
you know and so i'm becoming somewhat
confident in my ability to manage it
because
i've done lectures when i was you know
barely feeling able to drag myself onto
the stage
and
once i'm on there and
warm up a bit
you know it
it
it goes well and yeah i think part of
that too
and maybe you experience this as a dj
like i really feel that it's a privilege
to be up in front of the audience and
it's also a challenge to get them on
board right because we're all trying to
be in the same place at the same time
doing the same thing
and you have to have a real sympathy for
your
audience
in the deepest way you have to identify
with your audience
you know i think you have to feel
yourself as part of your audience rather
than the person who's
say lecturing to the audience
before you can bring everyone along
because it can't be a can't exactly be a
top-down thing
has to be a participatory thing
i always think of it in terms of this
kind of like energy
triangle or something it's like you give
off this thing and then it comes back to
you and then it goes back around again
and it's this
great that's going on even if it's it's
obviously unspoken in a dj capacity
you're not having a conversation with
words but you're giving them something
they're giving you energy in return in
response to what you give them and then
you build it and you build it and and so
on and so forth yeah that's it it's a
positive it's a positive feedback loop
yes exactly and you can i mean those can
go out of control but if you can keep
them modular i had to stop drinking
my reason for drinking well djing that
i'd given to myself as well i need to be
on the same level as my crowd they're
all drunk
so i should be a little bit drunk
but then uh then you get your thing
distorted and there's all there's well
as we know there's all sorts of
problems with drinking and uh the
nightlife industry is oh yeah it's
notorious functioning alcoholics oh
definitely well it's no wonder i mean
like a big part of
not all of it but a very big part of
what determines
the probability of
addiction is situation and the other
thing too is that someone like you or
another musician say or a bartender
nighttime people tend to drink more
so and it's partly because they're up at
night but it's also partly because the
way they're structured biochemically and
then of course you're always around
people who are drinking and then what do
you do after you're done your
sets i mean
it's
the party's on
so exactly wow
i've got this fixed now but yeah for my
first year in los angeles
los angeles everything shuts at two and
then everyone goes up to a mansion in
the hills and goes to another party
there and that's where all the business
deals go down supposedly and things
right i kind of fell into that world for
a little while until i realized that it
just wasn't proving as effective and i
had [__] to do in the daytime god damn
it well that's the thing that's that's
one of the best cures for
an addictive process is to have
something better to do than to be
hungover well this goes back to your
earlier question actually which is how
i've changed in the past since meaning
wave
and uh
i just don't have any room in my life or
any desire
for uh
anything unnecessary which is you know
any i don't want to drink
because i have this adventure i have
this really really useful thing to do
that's proving really really useful in
the lives of hundreds of thousands of
people and they tell me every day and uh
it's amazing in my life and it's amazing
in my family's life and
uh you know
i got really not really annoyed i don't
get really annoyed by social media but i
did see that
there was yet another vice story about
having kids is awful oh man that those
that's so brutal it's so anti-human it's
so cruel evil it is it's absolutely
especially cruel to women i think and i
had some poor women on my q a last week
tell me that all her friends are down on
her because you know she doesn't call
herself a feminist and because she wants
children they're just torturing her and
jesus it's so awful because
it's
like nietzsche said if you want to
punish someone you should punish them
for their virtues
and that's what's a brilliant and
unbelievably cruel statement and then to
find some perfectly normal healthy young
woman who
would like to have a family like every
single one of her ancestors had for
3.5 billion years and to tell her that
she's responsible for
you know
elevating the carbon footprint of the
planet and destroying the ecology is
just
god it's so
it's i just can't believe how cruel that
is and it's and it masquerades
in the guise of virtue which makes it
worse you know it's like jesus woman
have a child
have a husband have a have a career have
a life for god's sake there's not that
much to life
the meat where the meme that they're
putting out there is like you know if
you have children
like uh it costs loads of money and you
won't be able to do any of the things
you enjoy and it will be life will be
miserable when it's the very opposite is
true i am way
more
uh financially
uh
abundant or better off i don't know if
abundance the right word yeah in that
direction since having a child
my life is so much better since having a
child uh my motivations are so much
clearer the reason for being this is so
obvious
so much joy like un
unmeasurable levels of joy have come
from that one child and the only thing i
wish with regards to my life is that if
i was going to go back and have a
conversation with my earlier self is
just have lots of kids as soon as
possible
right
the earlier the better
there is no optimal time like hercules
wouldn't have happened if we planned it
we didn't we didn't plan him we always
thought well there's no intelligent time
to have a child no you're never ready
there's never enough money there's never
enough time
but it's it's the single most wonderful
motivating occurrence in this magical
blessed existence
uh that's how i've always
felt about
my kids
yeah you know um
well there's some there's a
variety of reasons you know one of the
things that has to happen to you
as you mature if you mature
is that at some point you have to
realize that someone is more important
than you
yeah
and i don't
believe that that can happen unless you
have kids because
it's actually not that easy to have
someone be more important than you
you know like if you fall in love with
someone
i would say
there may be times when you would
consider them more important than you
but i would say the general
equation is something like
well we're equally important to one
another
you know and and if it goes past that
sometimes it gets a little bit
well
questionable you know like well i would
die for you or i would do anything for
you it's like
that's a bit much you know
but with kids
it's not that at all it's like
their
number one
period
and you're not
and that puts
it's a relief to some degree i would say
but it also puts things in the proper
context and it
and it does
provide you with additional impul
impetus for
proper action and ambition
there's no room for error they're
looking at you
they're looking at to you for everything
you're completely responsible like you
know
if you're not the best version of
yourself
then what are they going to be
yes and then the mistakes you make are
going to echo through their lives as
well and then it's intergenerational
this is the thing i realized relatively
recently these
intergenerational ills that just keep
propagating down the line because
they're not fixed dr
well that's it you know is you get
someone in some generation they tear a
hole in the fabric of reality
and they pass it on to their children
and unless their children
sew up that hole
then they pass it to their children and
the damage remains until someone decides
enough
yeah i'm going to repair it
and you know that's partly what you're
trying to do as a parent is
sew up the fabric of being
so
a child will inspire you to sew up the
fabric of being like nothing else yeah
this is why i i'm terrified of
politicians without children frankly
because they have no skin in the game or
they certainly have less skin in the
game than uh than people who have a
vested interest in in the future not
being a horrible place to live
yes yes yes
well yeah well
i'm to it to any
women or men who are listening out there
that are of the proper age i would say
don't let the naysayers and the
pessimists and them
gloom
purveyors
and those who dare to compare human
beings to a cancer on the face of the
planet dissuade you from
having children
this is what the bad guys say in movies
that's what agent smith said in the
matrix he was the villain
he was the villain and the this ideology
is the idol the idea the ideology of
villains it's a very very strange thing
and uh you know they believe themselves
to be virtuous and
people who believe themselves to be
virtuous are terrifying because they
will do any kind of evil because they
think they're goody goodies that's
terrifying thing but as we were talking
about earlier i i'm very excited about
the future because the new generation is
going to react directly
against that the most punk rock thing
you can do in 2019 uh is
is get married and have a child and uh
take your life seriously and uh be nice
and be civil
god wouldn't it be something if that was
the case
this is what's going to happen i think
this is what's blossoming i think we can
have a
generation
of uh of radical wholesome mr rogers
well you're i think you're the most
optimistic person that i've talked to
for a long time i mean i talked to
stephen pinker you know
and he's
he's optimistic in a much more detached
way
because he thinks that the data
indicates that
economically
things
at a very rapid rate but you're you're
speaking of something more akin to a
psychological transformation
yes i am i am and this is just based on
on
observations but i believe this
and there's a lot that could go wrong
we're the best time to be alive in the
in in recorded human history
obviously uh we're also at the most
dangerous time because it could all
collapse right everything this wonderful
miracle that we inhabit i get to walk
outside and no one tries to break up my
head right yes which is which it's you
know you you you have to be sure that
one of the hallmarks of wisdom is to
understand that if you could walk
outside and no one throws a brick at
your head that that's actually a miracle
yeah
it is i know this so yeah because i grew
up somewhere people where people used to
throw bricks in my head so um oh
oh what was that all about
i
uh
i grew up in north wales and i was like
the only person like me i was the only
person who liked music and stuff of that
nature and everyone thought i was an
insane weirdo so i see
my life
people are very brutal in uh in the uk
certainly compared to los angeles to
america where people are very nice
compared to the brutality of that region
of the world and i think it's to do with
the climate you know it's a cold grey
rock and the other thing actually is uh
in america
everyone operates under the the
foundational assumption that anyone
could be president
so you know you have a service culture
and waitress isn't nice to you whereas
in the uk people operate under this
assumption that there is a monarchy
which means there's a level that you
could never get to or beyond which means
that there's this
weird unspoken thing that you're scum so
everyone everyone's a bit bitter and
twisted because of that i think for the
uk
but uh yeah anyway it was i had quite a
sort of tough upbringing and people were
very very mean i'm very very aware of
the capacity for
the nastiness
and species
uh and horror which uh so when i say
things like this about where i think
we're going this is an out of any kind
of uh of naivety right right that's
stevens i know full well what humans are
capable of yeah well that's good because
optimism without the
underlying
wise pessimism is useless
because you're not taking the
the
pro seriousness of the problem with
sufficient gravity because it's a
serious problem
yes we have some very serious
how old were you
when you started dissociating with
creative people and sort of found your
own crowd
well this goes back to what we were
talking about earlier so when i when i
was young i had no i thought i was the
only person like me on earth
i thought you know i was just strange
creature and i would be that life might
be this awful forever but i sort of you
know granted i left you know i left
school at 16 i left home at 16
and uh
left uh little sleepy little whales and
went to a big city and that's when i
started finding people like me right so
you needed to get you needed to get out
to the city
yeah i had to leave home and move to a
different country
well that's one of the issues of being
high in creativity you know is that it's
not that common
and you have to find
your niche and if you live in a small
place
there may not be any other people like
you and so you are going to be marked
out as someone who's strange because
you are strange by the dint of your
creative capacity it's virtually the
defining characteristic of creativity
the thing is now you can go online and
find loads of people like you right and
you could make and you could make art
with them and you could send files
backwards and forwards and you could
create things and also so it's
i'm interested to see what that does as
well
yeah well it certainly does mean that
that people of specific talents
rare talents can find themselves
in ways that they never could before now
it also means that people of
spare and rare pathology can also find
themselves and that seems to cause a
certain amount of trouble but i don't
see how it would be possible to get one
without the other
yes this is whether this is the thing
for every one of these amazing uh
solutions we find all these wonderful
gifts there's a shadow site of course we
have to deal with and that's the main
thing right is that we just work out how
to deal with it and okay so so two more
questions i guess one would be
what has been the shadow side of what
you've been doing
like with working with this meaning wave
you you you're much more well-known than
you were
has that had an effect on your life
other than a positive one and and what's
been the price that you've paid for this
you know it hasn't been so bad so far
you know the usual
some people
really really don't like you for example
and uh therefore me doing stuff with you
means that suddenly i've gone from a
hero in their eyes to a complete villain
and there's a few people
uh that's been the case with but
that's you know that's to be expected i
would say i would say that you know
the whole thing has been there's been a
blessing
the whole the whole thing has been a
blessing uh you know there's the amount
i'm working means i don't get to see my
family as much as i would like to there
is that yeah you know i'm work you know
working very hard uh but the time we
have together is that much more precious
and we're working together very much
together and we're supporting each other
and and uh
and you know we we see this as a a
useful and and helpful endeavor to be
engaged in and how much time are you
spending working a day
oh god um 14 hours or so 15 seconds yeah
you know it seems like that's about the
minimal amount of time that you have to
work if you really want to push yourself
to new levels of accomplishment
and that's every day
yeah every day
yeah it's it's very very difficult to
exceed expectations let's say
if you're trying to
work a normal eight-hour work day um i
my ex my experience with people is that
they're either not busy enough
or they're so busy they can barely keep
up
and that it's usually the ones that are
so busy they can barely keep up that are
pushing the envelope in whatever
discipline they happen to be pursuing
yeah and you know then you just have to
um there's concepts i heard of recently
which i like which i've been trying to
do
uh essentialism
you know when you're so when you get to
the point where you're which is a
wonderful point to be at where there's
suddenly more to do than you have time
to do with which i have fully there are
more albums i would like to make than i
physically have time to do in a lifetime
there are more uh speakers i would like
to cover there are more you know there's
more
more songs i would love to play more
techniques i would love to learn there
is far
more to do in this lifetime than than i
have life so then essentialism you boil
down what are the essential things
what things cannot fit and then you
you know then you streamline your life
and you do that
ever more ever more
remove things that are less essential
making room for the more essential and
then the more you know what the more
essential is the better idea you have of
where you're going or what you're trying
to do and how to do it yeah well that's
the separation separation of the wheat
from the chaff that's a real
that's a real skill if you can manage it
especially if the opportunities are
flying at you fast and furiously well
how do you what do you do
you presumably have more than you could
possibly hope to well i do a certain
amount of flailing about i would say
you know um
luckily what's happened is that
as
i've become better known
and i think this is an element of that
synchrony that you see
synchronism that you described earlier
is that
fortunately as
with each leap in
notoriety or popularity
i've had people show up who offered to
take certain tasks off my plate
you know in professional relationships
and
um
i've been fortunate that the majority of
those people have been very competent
and so and i do delegate like my
hiring
ethos is you want this job okay do it
i'm not going to micromanage you if you
can do it man great right more power to
you hopefully you can do it better than
me and if you can't do it well then i'll
have to find someone else well or we'll
have to find you a different place
because
there's just no point in you doing it if
you can't do it better than me
then
well then that's no good
i mean that's the ideal thing in life is
everything you're not the best at
delegate that to someone who is the best
at that great focus on the stuff that
you're the best well right and then you
can also continue to do more things and
yeah you know i i would say my wife and
i have been fairly ruthless well my
daughter as well probably my son as well
in the communication we've had about the
people we've hired over the last
three or four years because the time
pressure is so
intense
you know
if you can do the job man we're thrilled
to have you but if you have three or
four chances and you can't do it then we
just stop working with you immediately
because
we don't have any time for
error
it's and that the the costs of the
errors are too great
so but
you can delegate
so it's a difficult thing to learn to do
i i it took me a long time to be able to
let go because i did everything myself
for so long i taught myself how to do
every aspect of this sort of business
from uh the graphic design to making the
videos to recordings went to everything
right letting go of that is was a hard
thing to learn to do now now i'm very
happy to do that and if i can find
someone who can do something better than
me then wonderful i would much rather
than that but it did take a while it's
part of the whole ego well you have to
also master it to some degree before
you're capable of determining whether
the person that you've pulled in as a
replacement actually knows how to do it
yeah this is true
so there is that
work that you have to do yourself before
you're capable of
delegating and evaluating the
consequences okay so last question i
think
um
what's going to happen to you over the
next year
who knows
i'm going to work very hard okay i'm
going to get better i'm going to uh
stick to the the plan i set and uh
the hyper productivity and results of
this will will compound
so
where this leads
who knows but uh i do know that i will
make great music and it will be useful
in a great many people's lives
right so you've gotta you've got a
strategy
yes
and what do you what do you
what do you like about the hyper
productivity i mean one of the things
you said was that well you don't have
time to drink you don't have time to
waste time and there is something really
useful about hyper productivity in that
regard is that it it does
force you to dispense with everything
that's damaging and non-essential
because you just don't have the time
but is there anything else about
for about the hyper productivity that
you found um
let's say psychologically significant or
useful
i'm a lot i mean it's the thing is i
started the hyper productivity thing
exactly the same same time i started
uh
the carnivore diet
so sometimes i'm not sure which is
causing what
i used to about once a month go into a
kind of deep depression for a few days
which uh my wife would call my funk i'm
a very optimistic happy person normally
but then there would be
a little bit where i was kind of the
opposite i haven't had that
since wow congratulations how long has
that been that's 13 months
and what else is i wasn't going to ask
you about the diet but now i'm going to
what's happened to you because of the
carnivore diet
well i lost all my unnecessary body fat
how how much was that
um
i think i went from like 160 to 146 and
i've stayed at 146 about since and that
happened pretty quickly
like the first part of it was then days
like my face changed within a few days
this bloat i guess
inflammation likely
yes all that sort of thing i used to
have like sort of psoriasis and that
went i used to have like
my tongue was all messed up and yeah
that sorted itself out you started
bleeding gums and that's gone that's
gone eh that's interesting because that
went for me too yeah i used to have like
little bumps on my skin you wouldn't
really notice but like close up you
would that's all going on very smooth
skin now
um i've i have very consistent high
energy
um i used to sort of oscillate i guess
um it's made a lot of so there's all
those sorts of things
it's made life so much simpler and hyper
productivity makes life so much simpler
because when you know that certain
things have to be done without question
then there's no question right you know
it's like well i i can't go and do that
thing because i'm going to do this i've
committed right well that's the that's
advantage that's the advantage of having
a very well delineated aim me
yeah and a higher and a purpose you bet
it helps you separate what's necessary
from what isn't necessary and that is a
genuine relief no doubt about it it's
good it's joyful it's so much as so much
weight is cast off you
there's you know someone asks you to do
a thing
there's no debate you either do it or
you don't based on what what this aim is
what you're doing right same then
applies to things like food
like that one of the really annoying
things in my life
prior to the carnival thing was like the
daily what are we having for dinner
conversation and the the annoyances
related to that which is completely gone
i know what i'm having for dinner i'm
having a steak
and uh i know what i do having for
breakfast and the same thing you know
and i know what i'm drinking i'm
drinking water and i know i'm gonna feel
you know that i know i'm not gonna
suddenly be sleepy or bloated or weird
after eating something you know i'm
gonna be the same high energy
uh purpose that's a that's a major plus
so congratulations on that that's a huge
that's a huge beneficial transformation
so
let's end with this um
what do you think you're doing
with this
what's your like i know that you have a
name and an ambition you're making this
music you're making yourself hyper
productive you're concentrating on this
meaning wave but underneath all that
there must be a
what like an invisible or an implicit
ambition something like that a deep
ambition what what's your most profound
hope for what you're engaged in
personally i would like to become the
best
version of myself possible
um
you know the dragon ball x sort of final
form type thing that
the transformations that you go through
and there's these levels of you i want
to get to the nuke level
i want to get to get to nuke level and
be the best possible version of myself
possible as effective on every level i
can be
and with relation to the path i've
chosen which is this music thing
which is what i always
what always since i was you know my
earliest memories as being about seven
years old and uh listening to music and
wanting to make music
and uh reach people and communicate with
people on that
and specifically with regard to the
meaning wave
yeah well i think the meaning wave thing
is um
like so much we've talked about
we haven't scratched the surface of
what's possible with music we haven't
scratched the surface of what
it can do
and we have i haven't scratched the
surface of what i can do with it
i'm like this is a very what we're
listening to at the moment and the level
it's at right now is it is a very
neanderthal rough
approximate like uh
beginning of where it can go and what it
can do i think and i think that i think
that way with pop music pop music is so
new
you know just it just happened boom it
was just there and
and uh
you know we don't know
to quote you a bit we don't know what
the upper limits of this thing are right
right i'm very excited to explore this
so i think of myself a bit like
picard in deep space nine
going out
into this world
yeah well you've hit a vein that seems
rich
and you seem highly committed to getting
better and better at mining it
and so that's a good adventure and it
i mean from what i've observed with
regards to your trajectory over the last
while then
um
that all seems to be expanding nicely so
it's nice to have an adventure
where you you can't necessarily see the
destination but it looks positive
yeah well
i mean maybe it's not positive you know
maybe the adventure has a horrible
ending
it's it's an adventure regardless yes
this is true
there's something to be said for that
yeah
it's an exciting yeah we're at this
stage as we mentioned earlier we're at
this point of human development where
everything
our world we can we can barely imagine
the world in five years let alone 10 15
20. my grandmother's 96
she's the eldest of 13. uh she saw the
birth of the radio she was like you know
she was she left school at 13 windows we
saw tv and internet and all of this
stuff appear
like what what do what have we to
witness things that you know
things are speeding up so radically
uh
it's just just an incredibly exciting
uh time to be here and uh to be actively
taking part
in an aspect of it and sort of like you
know marching boldly forward
into unexplored territory
is uh about the best adventure i could
think of
well look it was really good to talk to
you i mean i've been watching what
you've been doing with a fair bit of
curiosity for quite a long time because
it certainly came as a shock to me when
it first came out and
it's
it's also refreshing to speak with
someone who's
unabashedly and not naively optimistic
and um
well a i hope we can meet
at some point in the relatively not too
distant future and b i wish you every
bit of success that you can have with
your hyper productivity and your
experimentation with music and
would like to thank you as well for
doing what you have to
popularize my
my work and my words in such a careful
manner
thank you that's that was my um
yeah i really didn't want to do
disservice to those words
um because i respect them greatly and
i'm very grateful for them and uh i'm
very grateful that you're out there
doing this work and uh
you know putting your head over the
the battlements at this crucial crucial
time in our development development as a
species as we boldly march into
hyperspace and our destiny so thank you
very good to meet you hopefully we'll
talk again in the not too distant future
i'm sure we will and i hope you like the
album
thank you i'm very much looking forward
to it nice
okay man i like it really good to meet
you yeah you too bye bye
peace